hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
apparently justin trudeau is still an
evil douchebag
i want to take a moment
to address um
in part the video we saw this weekend of
the deputy prime minister being
subjected to some extremely disturbing
harassment and threats
and this is not an isolated incident
sadly this is something we're seeing
more and more of certainly
members of this community have seen it
but we're seeing increasingly
people in public life people in
positions of responsibility particularly
women
racialized canadians
people of
minority
or different community groups
being targeted
almost because
of the increasing strength of your
voices
of your positions
of the impact you're having around the
world and around our country
we're seeing a backlash
and we've seen it you know first of all
over the past many years any time
a woman speaks up on social media
she is so often subject to harassment
and toxicity that we actually seeing
her rights and her voice and her freedom
of expression
diminished
we need
more
women
and racialized canadians
and diverse communities to be strong
voices in politics
in media where we're seeing
reporters increasingly getting attacked
for calling out hatred and indifference
and
and and
discrimination
we have to ask ourselves what kind of
country we are what kind of country we
want to be